live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create real
amazing relationships christina ellis
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money it is a free call
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two 825-5225
let's go to connor in baltimore hey
connor welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so basically um i just graduated two
years ago i lived at home throughout
that whole time did the commute thing
saved as much money as i could
so just a few months ago some things
went on at home and i basically had no
decision but to leave
and i've always wanted to buy because
you know i've obviously know that
renting is kind of a waste for some for
some reasons um
and i had really no choice so i have a
rent payment now i have a little bit of
debt um but i'm in a salary position in
a good career ladder and i guess i'm
just kind of wondering overall how i can
posture myself to put myself in the best
position moving forward cool what do you
do for a living
um so i work for the federal government
um
and i'm i make 63 000 a year good for
you okay cool what was your degree in
um business technology okay still like
data and analytics and stuff like that
good for you so you're what 22 23
24 yep 24. okay that's awesome how much
debt do you have
so um i have about three thousand
dollars in credit card debt um and
that's just because i had to move out
like very abruptly so i needed to
furnish stuff and just like that so i
just got like a bed and a couch and
stuff like that and just put it all on a
credit card
so
right now your your question is if you
should buy right now or stop running so
so basically
um
with the way the rent market has been
i've i'm spending way more than i should
be on rent because i really didn't have
an option
but i'm here for a year so then i guess
i'm just wondering i also have um like a
car payment and i probably bought more
car than i should have a year or two ago
just because i didn't anticipate on
having to pay rent so soon um so i'm
wondering how much of my money i should
be putting in to just kill that all that
debt off with the car and everything how
much do you owe and then
so i pay 400 a month and i have three
years left on it it's a toyota camry
what's the balance on it today
um i think 17 000 left i checked okay
big car payment so have around 20 000 in
debt total all right well uh there's a
couple things
we can certainly show you a system to
walk a out of this debt and then be into
a position you have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses that's
baby steps one two and three
and then start saving to buy a home at
that point
uh yes you do want to buy a home at some
point but uh
you don't want to buy them in the
headspace that you're in right now okay
and if you're going to ever win with
money
there's a phrase that you have said
three times in our conversation that you
have to stop believing and you have to
stop saying it
i didn't have a choice
dude you always have a choice
okay you needed to leave home i get that
but then you went and bought a bunch of
crap on a credit card uh you could have
gone down to
a garage sale somewhere and picked up a
used couch for 50 bucks
yeah you didn't but you didn't
okay so you always have a choice
uh you could have bought a car that you
could pay cash for but you didn't
you always have a choice
now so you you can you're no longer a
victim of
the marketplace or of your circumstances
you are
the uh captain of
your own ship and it's your destiny
marked on the side of that ship and
you're in charge of steering your
destiny
things are not going to happen to you
anymore you're going to happen to things
you've got to reset that narrative
because otherwise you're going to do
stupid butt crap the rest of your life
and blame it on i was forced to
yes sir okay make sense so now we'll get
that out of the way now it's real easy
to do the tactical stuff that you need
to do because you're obviously a sharp
young guy you've obviously got a lot on
the ball you're making really good money
at 24 years old you know you've got a
little bit of car payment you got a
little bit of credit cards we'll cut up
the credit cards we're going to get you
on a budget we're going to chop up get
rid of that credit card debt first and
we'll knock out the car payment and then
save for a down payment yes definitely
that sounds great i had one other
question too if you don't mind sure so i
i'm not really super into like um
like all of like the interest rates and
stuff like that and like what the
climate makes for a good time to buy a
home but the reason i didn't really buy
one was because i just heard everyone
saying you know you see it in the news
it's a terrible time to buy a terrible
time to buy how do you know when it is a
good time it's actually a great time to
buy so um
because house prices are gonna do
nothing but go up for the next five
years but you've got you've got some of
these characters on the news trying to
get someone elected or someone unelected
and they're they have an agenda and
they're so they're trying to use the
economy as a lever point on that um the
interest rates are up the market has
slowed down
um it is a better time to buy now than
it was last year at this time because it
was so white hot you'd been bidding
against 27 people
and uh so you know but let me tell you
what a bad time to buy is when you're
broke and not ready which is right now
right okay you got car payments and
credit cards and
uh you know you you haven't got a plan
and you feel discombobulated when you
buy a house in that environment you're
about to get screwed over
yeah connor i would say i would worry
less about what the market's doing right
now because yeah you're not ready i
think you've got to work through a lot
of the stuff yourself of course you know
we have the baby steps like dave said
get your own financial house in order
and also work through some of the stuff
that you went through with your family
that sounds like it was pretty
rough um and then you have a lot of
healing to do from that if you hang
online we're gonna get you a copy of own
your past change your future by dr john
dolone who's on the show and i would
really encourage you to go through that
and take a little bit of time because i
feel like right now i can hear the
anxiety in your voice and i can hear
this kind of franticness and i think
it's easy to point to you know maybe
it's because i need a house or maybe
it's because i'm not doing this in life
and i gotta hurry up and i gotta catch
up and it's like i think that's
channeled the wrong direction right now
i think you're focusing on things that
aren't gonna make you feel better in the
long run what's going to make you feel
better is dealing with your past and
finding a spot of peace and then dealing
with your finances the correct way
paying off all your debt saving a three
to six month emergency fund
investing for retirement and buying a
house you know do it all in the right
order but right now i think you got to
just take some time to breathe and kind
of reset it's wisdom christina that's
really that's really really wise because
here's the thing it's obvious from the
story we didn't dig into it
but that this was an emotionally violent
separation for you
uh the way you described it two or three
different sentences and talking about it
so um yeah we we all heard that and we
hear that in your voice too
and you make much better decisions from
a point of strength and a point of peace
rather than a wounded animal
and i've been both in my life at times
and i i i wounded animals don't make
good decisions
and so uh the healing she's talking
about is really really important and
it'll put you on this steady
rhythm of wisdom
and even how you go back and deal with
mom and dad later
you know and you're doing that from a
position of strength rather than
just barking and snapping and snarling
and
that can happen there really easy
so hang on we'll send you a copy of
john's book and also i will throw in a
copy total money makeover which will
show you exactly what to do with your
money and get things stabilized and walk
you through the baby steps
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
number one best-selling author ramsey
personality christina ellis is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
thank you for being with us
how many times have you found yourself
saying one day
when you're thinking about a goal one
day i'll be able to buy a house one day
i'll write a book one day i'll be happy
with my career one day i won't be deeply
in debt one day i'll have to battle i
won't have to battle with anxiety
anymore well stop waiting around
whatever your one day is you need to act
on it otherwise you're going to kick the
cans far down the road you run out of
road you need to get with this
you got to take a proactive stance on
all areas of your life and we help you
do that with smart conference smart
conferences where we take every area of
your life we bring in some of the top
thought leaders writers thinkers and
speakers on that area to help you get
smarter that's why we call it smart
conference that's a neat name yeah right
so anyway it's all day long on a
saturday and uh here's the deal like
we're gonna have rachel cruz talking
about money dr john deloney talking
about mental health ken coleman talking
about careers george campbell christina
ellis the new hottest uh ramsey
personality speaking in areas
christina's expertise is all around the
student loan world and all around the
education world and and george has
always got something fun and funny say
i'll be i'll be speaking my friends
craig and amy groschel from life church
will be talking on marriage it's all day
long and you're gonna leave smarter
it's in dallas this year it's october
the 22nd it is almost sold out but not
yet the vip and platinum passes are sold
out but you can still get general
admission only thirty nine dollars for
the whole day you would pay more than
thirty nine dollars here any one of
these number one best-selling authors
and virtually everyone on the venue is a
number one bestselling author many times
over at least once and have written
books and talk about and are
just experienced and world-class in
their space you're going to leave fired
up and wired up and so your one day
becomes today
today
i'm going to deal with this
and that's a cool thing ramsey
solutions.com
get your passes today
ramsay solutions.com events it is the um
it's the smart conference october 22nd
in dallas you don't want to miss this
this is your first one to speak it it's
my first one and i just saw the rundown
this morning and it looks incredible i
see why you say that you sit in the
audience and take notes because i never
miss oh man i always have a seat
reserved for the speaker the other
speakers and and people working and
stuff to come out there and sit during
the thing because i mean i've had we've
had all kinds of people uh you know
craig rochelle amy grochelle i mean when
i rachel cruz is my daughter but i
always learn something when she speaks
you know uh uh ken coleman he's always
got something going on in that brain of
his and deloney good lord he's got he's
got more degrees than a thermometer so
um you know and so you just yeah i'm
going to be sitting out there taking
notes and i'll learn something about
marriage i've been married 40 years but
i'll learn something about marriage and
i'll learn something from every one of
you when i'm sitting out there and if i
can learn something these are the people
i learn from then i know you people out
there listening can learn from them
absolutely yeah i can't wait to be on
stage but i also just can't wait to be
in the audience learning from everyone
because the talks look amazing but they
are the the content is
dialed in baby i mean it's really good
i'm so pumped all right bj's with us in
chesapeake virginia hi bj how are you
hi dave i'm doing good i'm over here
cleaning up our empty house so
but i'm good
sounds like a side hustle to me
it is it is i love it good good money
how can we help
well my question was i do have these
rentals
and
i have to pay rs somewhere 15 000 30 000
every year so my question is
should i take equity out just so some of
them are paid for so i'm concerned about
taking equity out just to
try to have other deductions
or should i just continue to pay our irs
i don't know
okay
uh
there are no tax deductions that make
mathematical sense
because if you give the government i
mean if you give the bank ten thousand
dollars and it is a tax deduction
because it was interest on us on a loan
right that means you get to deduct ten
thousand dollars from your income
so you do not have to pay taxes on
that ten thousand dollars
it does not save you ten thousand
dollars in taxes
it saves you having to pay taxes on ten
thousand dollars of your income and so
if you're in a 25 tax bracket it saves
you twenty five hundred dollars so you
gave the bank ten thousand dollars to
keep from sending the irs twenty five
hundred that's called stupid
okay we don't wanna do that very well no
we wanna we're not trading dollars for
quarters and look at that and call that
sophisticated financial planning okay
people do that crap all the time though
and some cpas are so stupid they
recommend you do that but you don't want
to do it okay now
here here's the thing why do you owe the
ir you you have a day job other than the
rentals
i don't work i mean i retired 2020. okay
so you've got income from retirement
that's taxable
and you've got the rev and you've got
the rents off these properties is
taxable
well i have other
income that i worked for i'm retired
military so i get income from that and
that's tactical because i'm the post
office i got money from that and that's
taxable
and i get the rental income and then i
get i'm a hundred percent disabled
that's not taxable from the middle
that's not that's not everything else is
though okay cool right so here's what's
happening
you just owe income tax
and you aren't setting it aside out of
your check
so if you owe 30 000 bucks a year that's
2500 bucks a month you need to be
setting aside
in your little irs savings fund over
here
okay you have to withhold on yourself
so that this doesn't come up smack you
in the back of the head every year
because if every time every year it
smacks you in the back of the head you
run borrow on it that's going to run out
that's right
yeah
okay
yeah using the home equity loan would
just be kicking the can down the road
you'd just be basically taking from
yourself in the long run so you've got
income that's taxable north of 100 grand
yes
way to go
thank you for your service by the way
well thank you thank you i mean you've
got you've so what are you
60
69 69 okay
all right yeah so
you what what you need to do is sit down
with a tax professional just go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on tax elp
because they need to help you set up a
cash flow schedule that every month when
you get checks you take some of that and
before you even put it in you put in a
checking account or whatever but
immediately it moves
x number of dollars over as if you were
doing a double like you when you worked
at the post office they held money out
of your check right so you just got to
hold money out of your own check
so this doesn't keep smacking you all
the time
you're amazing you put together quite a
life here
so don't put the on any of the ones that
you don't recommend equity line on any
of my paid off properties i paid off
four of them it's free and clear no i
wouldn't
now you have the money to pay the taxes
right now that are due
yeah oh of course yeah i pay all the
bills
everything is paid for okay savings is
coming in you know
so no so your main question is do i go
in debt to lower my tax bill
yes do i go into debt but see even if i
did that get an equity i could buy
another property
yes but you would be in debt and now
you've done all of this because this tax
thing is bothering you and if you owe
the bank ten thousand dollars in
interest you only save twenty five
hundred dollars on taxes bad trade again
okay so i i would rather see you
uh set up a schedule where your taxes
are coming out of your check that you're
taking them out automatically and you're
not getting you're not feeling the pinch
of these things because you're planning
better number one and then i want you to
use some of this money because you don't
spend much money and i think you're
going to be able to pile up enough cash
pretty quickly to buy another property
with cash and not have any debt
there's a reason you work to get all
these paid off kiddo
yeah
because life's better when they're paid
off don't go back in debt
yeah
okay yeah you're feeling the pressure
from the tax thing because it's just bad
cash planning is you got bad cash
planning
yeah bj you're such a rock star just
even the fact that right now when you
called you said you're at the rental
cleaning it yourself at 69 years old
like you have worked hard for this then
that's incredible just keep doing what
you're doing because you have
proved that you know what you're doing
yeah and you can't borrow your way out
of this you gotta you gotta plan and
work your way out of it
and and that's that's a thing but it's a
misnomer that
and you can only write off interest by
the way if you're itemizing and most
people don't itemize anymore the
standard deductions are so high very few
people itemize so it's really mythology
i'm going to stay in debt on my home
because i get a text right write-off you
really don't you know if you're taking
standard deduction you don't get a tax
write-off on your home
because your standard deduction is
covered
you've got that whether you have debt or
not
silliness yeah
this is the rams you show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
christine ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
thank you for joining us america amy's
with us in dallas texas hi amy how are
you
i'm great mr ramsay how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up um i
think it's a quick question
i know you stress mutual funds but i was
just curious um if i have research and
both have a proven track record of you
know 10 to 12 percent growth
over the long haul does it matter if i
choose an etf or a mutual fund really no
they do about the same thing
okay
the thing you don't want to get into and
a lot if you're reading about etfs and
you
go down the rabbit hole on one of these
stupid reddit threads or something like
that then you may find people using etfs
to do to try to time the market
and jump in and out never never gone on
reddit my whole life good that's that's
a wise thing
uh i don't go i haven't gone back in a
long time but um my team tells me from
time to time stuff that's going on
and uh but yeah it's like reading the
comments after an article you understand
why some species eat their young and so
um but the uh
does dumbest humans on the planet but
yeah the uh anyway the etf if you're
going if you get off i'll use another
one if you go off on one of these stupid
tick tock things or something like that
so where you're getting all this
financial advice from goobs or trying to
figure out some get rich quick thing
okay don't use an etf that way if you're
simply using it like a mutual fund it
basically is a mutual fund it's kind of
how it acts
okay great it's very very very similar
would you agree with what you've learned
about it
yes i i think i was mainly going for a
more efficient tax thing so i didn't
have to like
plan for the mutual fund less tax
efficient that's what i was going for so
you've maxed out all your retirement
yes sir
excellent and you're 100 dead free house
and everything yes sir way to go how old
are you
uh 33 1332
ding woohoo yeah the etf will give you
the same benefit on the tax efficiency
that like a an s p 500 would an index
fund if you buy a low turnover mutual
fund
you know that means they don't sell the
stocks inside of it very often has a low
turnover ratio
that's what i do in your situation baby
step post baby step seven stuff you're
100 out of debt 100 maxed out on
retirement now where can i put some
money and not get my butt taxed off
right exactly and and
so the etf will let it sit there and
basically it's capital gains growth a
low turnover mutual fund like an index
500 s p 500 would it's basically capital
gains growth so you don't pay taxes on
it until you cash it and if you've held
it a year and cash it then you're going
to be taxes taxed at capital gains rate
rather than full ordinary income rate so
it's very tax efficient i love them for
that purpose yeah in your setting super
super yes but just don't want everybody
else out there listening at 22 million
listeners thinking oh i can buy and sell
and i'm going to jump in the market and
out of the market and use the etf to do
it which is a lot of times when you hear
people doing these stupid motley fool
articles or something like that that
don't know what they're doing they're
teaching you to do that kind of stuff
timing the market is bad
but etfs in general i don't have any
issue with them
so i'm super impressed 33 years old
killed baby step 7
mic drop
i love it i'm hung on that i'm like
that's just fantastic you go girl
abigail's with us in rapid city south
dakota hi abigail what's up
hi it might be a little windy where i am
i am i'm currently working and i'm
outside but
my boyfriend and i are looking to move
in together and we can't agree on
whether to
rent an apartment or buy a house
together
buying house together without being
married just doesn't seem right to me
and i'm looking for some advice
well i think you're definitely on the
right track with that i would not
recommend buying a house with somebody
you're not married to that can open up
so many doors to
complications
what's your kind of timeline for wanting
to make a move
um within
three to six months
okay
how old are you guys
um we're 20 and 22.
20 and 22.
okay
if you're willing to talk about buying a
house
and you're willing to move in together
why aren't you willing to get married
um we're we're young yet um we are high
school sweethearts young people get
married all the time
yeah i know and we've been talking about
i think we'll probably get married
within a year or two
or we're uh i'm calling because we're
going to have a serious conversation
this weekend because
i want to get forward with our
our plan of when we're going to get
married and how much the wedding should
be
possibly so
yeah
okay so
um
you you called asking advice about the
house and about the whole situation i'm
going to give you more than you asked
for
okay okay
there was a the brookings institute did
a study
that said in america if you do three
things your probability to avoid poverty
is statistically
astronomical in other words the
likelihood of being in poverty if you
avoid these three things
is very very high
marry before you have a kid
have your first child after age 20
and get married before you live together
that's a statistical analysis
okay
and uh
the chances of divorce for people that
live together before they get married
are four times higher
than people who get married before
living together
statistical evidence
interesting
so yeah if uh
my youngest is 30.
uh when they were
in their 20s if we had been having this
conversation i would say why do you
think you can beat the odds
there must be some reason behind all of
this
there must be some reason behind all
this so if bubba is willing to
sleep with you and buy a house with you
he should be willing to marry you
that's my dad talking
all right okay see i told you it was
getting more than you looked for
you know and you know what abigail it's
not because i'm trying to make you mad
i care about you kiddo and i want you to
win and you called here looking out a
win
yep i did so thank you so don't buy a
house for god's sakes or somebody you're
not married to
because when you break up it's very very
difficult when somebody dies or becomes
disabled it's very very difficult
when someone gets on drugs it's very
very difficult
yeah i thought just like even applying
for a loan when we're not married would
be complicated and i just didn't want to
do that and also
we're just dating i didn't want to have
to deal with the burden of home
ownership yeah so agreed agreed
so yeah rent for sure
uh
and uh but you need to consider these
other statistics as well
uh i kind of got the vibe you're not but
um that's okay it's my job to tell you
it's your job to decide what you're
going to do you're like a grown up and
stuff
well and you have a few days to think
about it like really
take some time think about it pray about
it evaluate before you have this
conversation get your own emotions
settled because i mean i think you do
have an opportunity to really
have some of those harder conversations
about where's this relationship going
what's the timeline and it sounds like
you know you guys have a at least the
ability to have the conversation so if
that conversation's happening this
weekend you know just take some time
before it happens to consider what dave
said and see if there's a more wise way
to approach it no
if you're serious enough to make all
these big life decisions then you're
serious enough to make a big life
decision so how old were you when you
got married 23 23 i was 22. yeah so
young people get married all the time
and then you've been married how long
10 years and i got 40.
that's amazing so
you know it works yeah it's an amazing
thing yeah yeah
and um
there you go well in successful
marriages they're built on those hard
conversations like being willing to have
those hard conversations about yeah
maybe he wants to move in with you or he
wants to wait longer to be married but
then you have to have your boundaries as
well the part of your brain you're using
to make a permanent commitment when you
buy a house
is a pretty similar part of your brain
that you use to make a permanent
commitment when you decide to get
married
because once you're in the house deal i
mean you you got the you got the brand
on your forehead you know i mean you're
there
and you're you're stuck in this deal
and so uh
it's a very very similar
set of critical thinking skills that get
you there now i know you're in love and
i know all this and i i know he's very
persuasive
um
well especially if you're buying a house
too like you're signing on a dotted line
for that as well that's that's pretty
intimidating if you're not married
yeah it's uh
it's hard to get out of either one
marriage or house owning ownership
both are messy so yeah you need to be
really sure what we're doing here with
permanent decisions long-term decisions
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
number one best-selling author christina
ellis
ramsey personality who's been married 11
years not 10 is my co-host today um
sorry sorry husband
so uh
yeah there's a there's one year in there
that just didn't count
it wasn't much of a year it's kind of
boring here not much going on
i blame mom brain
mom brain oh okay all right
all right there you go that's it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five kelly is with us
in baltimore maryland hi kelly welcome
to the ramsey show
hi oh my gosh it's such an honor thank
you for having me
our owner too how can we help
i
am
drowning in student loan debt um i have
three hundred thousand dollars on
student loans oh honey
yeah
what's your degree in are you a lawyer
or a doctor
a lawyer okay that's good news
i hope i hope you got a good lawyer job
you didn't take a work take a job with
the state or something
the government federal government why
uh work-life balance so uh work-life
balance you got 300 000 in debt
i know
um i did have a mental health breakdown
back in
2018 and that pre i couldn't find a job
so the government was the first one that
came up at the end of 2019 and then the
pandemic hit
yeah how much i paying you
uh my gross is eighty nine thousand
eight hundred thirty four
okay how long have you been on law
uh
school
how are you doing with your mental
health
uh better i see a therapist bi-weekly um
that's a part of my my my budget is that
i have to pay my co-pay for my therapist
and i see the psychiatrist quarterly so
then i take medication good investment
good investment well done thank you
sounds like you're doing better
i am much better and
um
realizing that i gotta
get a hold of all of this
my wife
i'm not married but i still am with my
children's father
okay
how many kids do you have
three
what
age sixteen
seven going on eight and four going on
five
okay
all right um
well you gotta you got a mountain to
climb here and so we got to get our
climbing gear out and uh
the hole that you're in is 300 000 the
shovel that you have is 90 000
right
yes your income we call it the shovel to
hole ratio your income versus the amount
of debt you got to climb through
and so i start going okay out of 89 out
of 90 000 how quick can i pay off 300.
if i pay off 30 a year that's 10 years
that doesn't work
yes too long i even tried to
work some things out and i'm like this
feels too long
it was like five i measured like six
years and i was like that's like five
thousand more months and i'm like i
don't know
i do uh try to work on the side i need
to um
i do
probate
and some estate planning but it's just
been slow going
only 500 there 500
so now that things are settled a bit
after 2018 and the pandemic and
everything are you open to finding a
different job that maybe pays a bit more
um i did not think of it no i didn't i
am open but i did not think of it yeah
okay because you you need to you could
probably make 160 you probably double
your income 170 if you got out there in
private practice
um
and
i mean it might take a little bit of
time to get there but
you're not going to get there in the job
you're in
and you need a bigger shovel
mathematically the arithmetic tells us
that because if you could put
80 on this you'd be done in three or
four years
but you can't put 80 on it when you make
90. you can when you make 180.
and yeah there's going to be some
work-life balance
but i'm going to go with some work-life
balance
uh like that mom's going to work because
mom has a mess
and uh i'll see you in about three years
well and especially if you make that
shovel bigger then it's less about side
hustling and working 80 or 90 hours it
might be at a new law firm a private law
firm they might put her in there that's
true and
lock her on the fifth floor not let her
out but um but at least you'll have the
the income there like your salary will
be a lot stronger than what it is
currently
here the probability of you getting this
mess cleaned up increases the more you
can shorten how long the pain is going
to be
and so i i for your sake i i think
you've got to reconsider
how you can go make double what you make
or you know
almost double what you make and throw it
all throw all the difference at it
because i mean does it not sound pretty
appealing to be out of debt in three or
four years
yes
i mean i would give up i would give up a
lot of stuff to do that i would give up
a lot of a sacrifice to do that when we
started this company i worked my kids
were your kids age or younger and for
three years my wife will tell you she
was virtually a single mom when we
started this company but if you work
like no one else later you get to work
like no one else
and if you live like no one else later
you get to live like no one else and
here's the thing the the amount of time
that human beings in america waste in
front of the television
really cause you to prosper alone
and you don't you can't call work
sitting in front of the television work
life balance because children aren't
getting anything out of that except
watching mom and dad zone out watching
netflix and tiger king
and so um you know i i
i don't recommend working 80 hours a
week and never seeing your children as a
way of life
but for a short period of time to get
some kind of a needle to move yeah hard
work never killed anybody right before
you die you pass out if you're working
hard
so you're not gonna die from it
well good job having the courage to call
you've been through you've been through
a lot yeah that's that's and you have a
huge mountain ahead but we have seen
people pay off 300 dollars in debt
here's the thing the looming
monster
that's
thirty thousand pounds three hundred
thousand pound monster here
three hundred thousand dollar monster
there's a stress
and a weight
to that
that dr john deloney
you know our resident psychologist says
your body
feels that weight
it affects your mental health
and so for you to
continue the healing you have to see a
way out of that
instead of seeing that as this endless
rock you have to push up the hill
as in greek mythology right and so uh
you know you push the rock up the hill
and you get to keep pushing it up the
hill for the rest of your life that
there's that the weight of that
hopelessness
affects your mental health it affects
literally your physical body feels that
as a from a mental health perspective
your physiological reactions to the debt
and so um
you know you even if the
news is hard
hope that it's going to be over soon
i can deal with the hard news
right yeah the human being human mind
can be a psyche can deal so my point is
it's going to help your mental health to
have a plan that gets you out right yeah
the idea of carrying around 300 000 in
student loan debt for the rest of your
life that sounds terrifying i think
anybody would feel that pit in their
stomach and just such a
just a rough feeling feeling like that
monster is chasing you and it's right
there all the time but yes there is hope
this is scary right now
but you can tackle this you can tackle
this mountain as hard as it is
i think especially given the career that
you're in given that you can get a
bigger shovel and really attack this i
understand how you got to the career and
i'm not shaming you for that i would
tell you not to stay there though
because i think it's good for you good
for your finances good for your kids
good for your mental health good for
your career for you to go make a big
pile of money and get this mess behind
you yes
and so that that's why i'm saying all of
this it's not just to get you out of
debt
because there's so much more to this
picture
and uh but it's
uh uh
the number of families that we have had
with small children
that
both spouses the kids ended up at
grandma's half the time because they
were hustle grind they're working two
three four jobs and 18 24 36 months
later they've cleared all the debt now
they can work 40-hour jobs the rest of
their life and become very very wealthy
and the kids are not harmed by that
because it's not a permanent way of life
we're not working for the wrong reasons
we're working for a short period of time
with intensity with gazelle intensity
for focus get it knocked out that does
not harm your children no and those are
the best debt-free screams when we hear
them in here just yelling at the top of
their lungs that they did it it is so
powerful and we hope to see you here
kelly in a few years amen amen this is
the ramsay show
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place in
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships we're glad you're
with us america thanks for being here
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two
five
daryl starts off this hour in california
hi daryl how are you
i'm doing fine good how can we help
i'm wondering why the
saving for kids college is part of the
baby steps i don't know i don't quite
understand why i should hand my
kids that
um
that luxury
just give it to them i feel like if i
build in the expectation that they can
work out into it themselves
then it'll mean more and it'll actually
get them further in their life in their
career so i don't understand why that's
in the baby steps okay
well i i don't disagree that um a lot of
what you're saying is true
um
the uh but i will put out
you can teach people
uh you yes if you work your way through
and if you learn self-reliance and uh
you and i are cut out of the same kind
of cloth i i don't disagree with your
sentiment at all
um
the other thing though is uh uh
i've actually proven
that paying for your kids college
doesn't ruin them
because i paid for mine and mine are all
three very productive
very ambitious
scratch claw
have good work ethic good character
love god love their spouses
take care of their kids and so on they
all three turned out so i didn't ruin
them by paying for their college but
obviously i installed the things you and
i are both concerned about into their
walk as as their dad
along the way
so that by the time they got to college
i didn't do that but are you under a
moral obligation to pay for their
college no that's not why it's in the
baby steps
uh if you don't want to under the
auspices of what you're saying i
wouldn't disagree with you i think
you're fine doing that
uh but
but i i would disagree to say it's the
only way they turn out is if you make it
make the road hard for them
that's not true no i agree with that
yeah
well we meet so many parents who are you
know they have students in high school
and they wish that they could pay for
their kids education but they didn't
think about it in advance so this really
kind of gets people thinking early on if
that's a desire for them to pay for
their kids college education
it gets them thinking early on you know
how are we going to do this financially
how can we save in the right way in
order to make that dream a reality and
of course it's not and not every parent
wants to pay for their kids education
you know a lot of people get
scholarships i had to pay for college on
my own and that's the journey for a lot
of people but a lot of parents do want
to pay for it and then they get to the
you know junior and senior year and it's
kind of a little bit too late in their
savings plan so then their kids end up
in a lot of student loan debt that's why
student loan debt is one of the largest
stats in america right now so it's
really just trying to help students
avoid that yeah
right exactly so i christina i would
both agree with you we both did the
thing i mean her her dad passed away
when she was a little girl and so her
mom was a single mom and uh so she her
only way to go to college and mom sat
her down and said we got to get
scholarships so she became the america's
leading scholarship expert in the
process and got a half a million dollars
worth and scratched and clawed and not
only got a degree but got a postgraduate
degree and took care of every bit of it
herself her mom didn't pay a dime of it
and it didn't hurt her it's one reason
she's able to sit here at this table at
her young age because she's because
she's got the stuff you know that you're
talking about daryl so that's all really
really good and so i would agree with
you
that there is no moral construct that
requires them to be in the baby steps
but you would have to agree with me that
the vast majority of people
say
i would like to save something and help
my kid go to college and so we need to
give them a vehicle a place to do that
and order in which to do that and that's
why it's baby step five
but it's not baby step four you have to
support it honestly do what
honestly i just can't it's not
financially responsible for me to be
saving for that it's two there's too
much else that i need those
numbers need to go somewhere else well i
mean i'm still 12 years out plus even
but there's no way it'll pencil out i
mean i could save some toward that yeah
well that's cool that's okay too it's
not just yeah but it's not there it's
not there to guilt-trip you say you're a
bad guy
it's not it's not it's not to say you're
a bad dad if you don't
well there's no shame in saying you
can't i mean that's what my mom said to
me is like she just couldn't even
should i no not necessarily
it is not a moral obligation
and
to your point it's right now i will tell
you this
if you're going to be
the dad or mom that says um
i can
but i'm not going to
because i want you to
be able to
to hoe this row so to speak i want you
to be able to push through this i want
you to learn hustle i want you to learn
grind and the lessons you're going to
get from the being able to pay for it
are as valuable as the things you learn
if you're that dad or mom which is how
you started out the conversation daryl
and i again one more time don't disagree
with you what you do have in that
situation the uh the moral obligation as
a parent you do have is you need to show
them how they can do it talk to them
about getting good grades so they can
get scholarships talk to them about
choosing a college that's affordable not
a super expensive college that they
can't afford talk to them about studying
something that matters don't get a
degree in left-handed puppetry and then
end up as a barista with 200 000 student
loan debt you know talk to them about uh
hard work and working and working and
working and working and working and
working and working i worked 40 to 60
hours a week for four years while i went
through school
and i didn't die from it and it's not
child abuse
exactly
yeah that was i'm right there with you
dave that was one of my thoughts is just
one of the best gifts that my mom gave
me when she told me that she couldn't
afford my education the fact that she
sat down with me after that and said
okay so this is where we are financially
i can't pay for your college but they're
the coach and a cheerleader exactly she
walked me through it she gave me ideas
she helped challenge me good luck with
that right sorry about your luck or she
didn't wait till senior year and then
saying such to be you
yeah no it didn't didn't do that yeah
yeah you gotta you gotta walk with them
and say okay listen here's the reason
i'm doing this i want you to get some
calluses on your hands here's the reason
i'm doing this i can't do it here's the
reason we're doing this it's good for
you to learn how to problem solve now
i'm going to walk with you i'll help you
with the problem solving i'll be your
biggest cheerleader i'll be your biggest
coach i'm going to push you i'm going to
love you uh and if you can do that
then you know you may you may end up
with a really positive result out of
this with some kids particularly
but um and by the way all three of my
kids while i paid for their school
worked while they were in school
if they because they were on a tight
budget and then a bunch of money screw
around with if they wanted to go do
something else they had to come up with
the money to do that
and so like my youngest who's one of our
top executives at ramsey today many
years later he's still the ramsey family
uh mattress expert because he worked at
a mattress store so anytime we need to
know something about mattresses we asked
daniel because he knows all about
mattresses he learned all about because
he sold the crud out of him i mean he
was good good mattress salesman
they they didn't like it when he
graduated because they lost one of their
best salesmen so um you know it doesn't
none of this hurt it's a good thing hey
hang on daryl i'm gonna send you a copy
of the book debt free degree and i'm
gonna send it to you free and it coaches
you through and coaches how to go to
college debt free
if your parents aren't paying for any of
it
and uh it can be done it can certainly
be done this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina alice ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
i think it's important to circle back to
that last call for just a second because
i really
appreciated where daryl was coming from
on a couple of different fronts
one is it's not a moral obligation for
you to pay for your children's college
education you haven't been a bad parent
if you didn't
and two uh if you're in a position like
your mom
or like daryl was saying he was having
trouble putting the money together um
you're
we need to say really really loudly
but since it's not a moral obligation
you're not a bad parent it's not like
you didn't feed them it's not like you
didn't clothe them
it's not like you didn't keep the heat
on those are your responsibilities hello
uh moms and dads right but paying for
stuff for them
you know it's a it is he called it a
luxury it is a luxury and so the number
of times i've been sitting at the
end of a stage after a seminar signing
books and a lady particularly ladies i
see it will come up that are single moms
and they're just
overwhelmed
with the
weight of that they're a bad mom
because they have no money to pay for
their kids college
because they're i mean they're working
three jobs just to eat a lot of times
and then then somehow the culture has
put this thing on if you don't save for
college you're a bad mom
yeah your mom's she's she's
more like me she's like i don't care
what anybody thinks
i don't have any money and so we're
gonna figure this out you know but she
she wasn't burdened by guilt i don't
think no i don't think that was her
style
yeah
uh but uh but i mean i i see these
people who are sweet and not saying your
mom's not sweet i'm i'm saying they're
they're they're not coming at this with
the same way daryl was or your mom did
they're coming at it and going
the the the weight of
i you know i've got a 16 year old i make
34 000 a year i have no money
and thereby i'm not paying for college
the arithmetic tells us that and then
they they internalize this message that
they're a bad mom
or a bad dad and you're just not that's
just not true it's just not true well we
even meet people who are you know
towards the end of their baby step two
they're paying off debt and they just
they didn't know to save they didn't
plan to save early on and they also feel
that shame they feel like they got a 16
year old and they're not gonna have two
hundred thousand dollars safe they're
not gonna have a hundred thousand
dollars saved yeah in a year and a half
before the kid goes to college and it's
not so you have to do the other things
and so um that's where the debt the
debt-free degree book came from and uh
it's helped a lot of people your book
that you did confessions of a
scholarship winner i say that right yep
um was the number one bestseller and
christina as we've told the story 100
times is half million dollars worth of
scholarships she went and scratched up
so this stuff can be done
and we talk about this a little bit but
probably not as much as i would have
liked to have had in our documentary
called borrowed future
and borrowed future
we dropped our first full-length film
it became a big deal last year uh it's
still out there you can still watch it
on google play apple tv amazon prime
and it's a full-length
you know world-class documentary on the
horrible
condition of the student loan the epic
crisis that is the student loan industry
right yeah and it actually shows you
know
what's behind it why it's so toxic and
also how to avoid it it's such a cool
documentary because it's like it shows
not only
people who are struggling with student
loans and people who are just weighted
down and really tells their stories but
it also you know shows students who did
it a different way and kind of opens
people's eyes to the fact that there are
very different paths that you can go if
you've got a teenager and you need to
watch borrowed future yes period well
that's the thing it's like i've been
working with high school students for so
long it's an amazing resource to have
because so often you tell them the words
you say you should avoid student loan
debt you're going to regret it if you go
into debt but to have actual stories and
a visual picture of why the industry's
toxic and people who are crying because
of the death that they took on and the
the pain that it's caused its life it's
it's just such a
powerful picture for a young person to
see to really paint out for them yeah
the academy awards of on-demand
documentaries on the internet which is
one of the things that we are obviously
were a long-form documentary
is called the webby awards i didn't know
this but i learned it recently and it's
presented by the international academy
of digital arts and sciences well there
you go the leading international awards
organization that honors excellence on
the internet this year's webby awards
received 14 000 entries from 50 states
and 70 countries
um the uh our
borrowed future it's got christina in it
it's got dr john deloney in it uh david
ichiko on our team was the producer on
it he pulled the whole thing together
director mike rowe is in it our friend
mike rowe from dirty jobs is in it seth
godin one of the best marketing minds on
the planet is in it um and a bunch of
real cases and so
you need to watch borrowed future
tonight but anyway we ended up i didn't
know what it was but now i do because
it's really heavy and it's important and
we won
the webby award yeah so borrowed future
is award-winning uh
the uh we got the number one documentary
in long form borrowed future right there
and so there's the webby awards big old
spring pretty cool
and uh very heavy i picked it up and
went whoa that thing's ridiculous so
pretty cool though i didn't know they
existed and i didn't know we
were up for an award and then all of a
sudden we are an award so there you go i
like it i think so uh it was the number
one documentary uh
for weeks on google play it was the
number one number two documentary on
apple tv and it was the number five
documentary rent or by category on
amazon prime so a lot of viewership on
it and we're very very proud of it and
uh encourage you guys to check it out um
not because you need to help us or
something i mean it's like three dollars
to watch it and we get 27 cents or
something so it's not like we're getting
rich off the thing you don't make any
money on these things but the uh it's
not a money maker but it is a it is a
thing where we wanted to poke into
this toxic culture and stir up a ruckus
and buddy it stirs up a ruckus we have
pissed some people off of this thing
because these student loan people man
they're freaking evil
the stuff they are doing behind the
scenes is straight up
it's out of some kind of
book or something i mean it's like
it's hard to believe people actually do
crap like that to 18 18 year olds yes
it is it's a it is a filthy
filthy business
and uh and you and i the taxpayers are
are guaranteeing these loans which makes
these goobers out there these crooks
able to do this stuff it's unbelievable
the collect the navient people the
sallie mae people
oh you got to watch this thing man it'll
blow your mind
yeah so borrowed future
and the message overall is this number
one
message borrow future is student loans
suck
and the people around them suck so avoid
this thing okay number two message is
you can go to school
debt free it is possible and it has a
whole lot to do most of the time with
school choice
choosing one you can afford
and um you know
very few people ask when they're hiring
you or when you're doing work with them
or anything else
what where you went to school
and uh you know i
don't know where my doctor went to
school
i don't know where my lawyer went to
school i don't know where my tax guy
went to school
i know that they have been academically
trained because they're licensed in
those areas but i really don't know
where they went to school all i want to
know is can you fix this it's broken
that's all i want to know
and that's you know and if you can do
that then i don't really care where you
went to school my tax thing is you know
screwed up you got to fix it okay you
know that's it estate planning whatever
it is i there's all these people in
and you know but people walk around
acting like where they went to school it
doesn't nobody cares
nobody cares it's a joke well they're
just i think that's one of the big you
know myths or lies around higher
education that has become ingrained in
society and is a huge reason why
people are taking on crazy amounts of
debt they think you know i gotta go to
the college at all costs and that's just
not true no not that college
um listen you can go there if you want
to go there i don't mind you going there
i'm not mad at you i don't make fun of
you for being a harvard graduate
unless you paid full sticker for it then
i'll probably make fun of you but um
but please don't don't come in here
telling me
that you are more likely to be a success
because of where you went to school
there's absolutely zero research that
indicates that none you cannot find a
data point anywhere i've been in this
business for 30 years it's not there
so quit overpaying for this crap
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know when people change their lives
when they finally say that's it i've had
it
no more i'm done
when that rises up inside of you like
that you're ready to change your life
and um you're tired of waking up at 2 30
in the morning worried about how you're
going to fill your gas tank
yeah i've had it
tired of wondering how you're going to
put supper on the table with the dead
gum prices or keep these lights on i've
had it i'm not living like this you make
too much money to be as broke as you are
you should say i've had it
when are you going to get sick and tired
of being sick and tired
well for a limited time we're bringing
back the ramsay 10 sale you can get your
hands on our number one best-selling
books like the total money makeover
that's helped eight million people at
this stage of the game that's if
everybody only one person ever read one
book but multiple books out there and
we're making it easy to get expert help
you get free financial coaching with any
purchase on any of these books
that's pretty cool
and you can talk with ramsey preferred
coach about your specific money
questions and plans they'll help you
make goals to stick to them so you can
go from i've had it
to
i've got this
enough with the worrying
enough with everybody else controlling
your life
enough with the disgust when you look
down to see how much you make and you're
still broke
enough with the losing sleep
take control of your money get your life
back
get one of these books at the 10 sale at
ramseysolutions.com or get your butt in
financial peace university and get this
stuff turned around it's time
it's time
you've been dancing around the edges of
this stuff
and you're ish and ish is a wish
i didn't know financial coaching was
included that's that's a that's a sale
we're running right now we've never done
that before and it's going zoom zoom
people are loving it they're because
they get a free coaching session because
everybody wants to you know they don't
want to call in on the show because
they're afraid i'll be mean to them but
our coaches are nice
and so i'm not mean to you i just love
you and tell you the truth and i don't
have a lot of time so i tell you real
fast
that's all it is but yeah but the uh
but the uh uh that's the thing and the
other financial coaching is a deal yeah
with a ten dollar book hello yeah the
book's already a thirty dollar book
hello so i mean a hardback being this is
a book you'll keep on your show for the
rest of your life i got books that have
changed my life the information in them
changed my life and i've they're they
got sticky notes and highlighters are on
my shelf i'll never give those books
away there's some books when you move
you throw them all out you give them to
goodwill or whatever but
not those not those
alex is in new york hey alex welcome to
the ramsay show
hello dave and christina how are you
great how can we help
all right thank you very much um i'm a
social studies teacher and this summer i
got a second job as a server i'm
currently on baby step number two and
i've worked really hard um with student
loans
the interest being paused to um um crack
down and get my debt lowered good my
call today um thanks my call today is i
have a 2007 jeep liberty um and
currently there's a check engine on
and there's an issue with the catalytic
converter i've done some research on my
end and that's going to be two thousand
dollars to fix
and i already have the baby step number
one of just saving two thousand dollars
first and foremost
stop stop stop who said is gonna take
two thousand dollars to a catalytic
converter
um that's just i've researched the part
and i've talked to um
like mechanics who said that they would
they would do it for two thousand
dollars
um
okay
is it an inline catalytic converter in
the muffler system it should be right
yes
gulp i wanted a junkyard man
um well i guess okay i might have to do
that as well my real question mike the
reason why i called is do i save do i
spend the 2000 to fix it or do i it's
really like rental car army not used
cars right now are
much more than two thousand dollars
right now um or do i save a little bit
more but also knowing that my check
engine light is on and it's kind of
dangerous sweet driving with that so
just want to pick your brain and see how
like you try to manage that situation
yeah
okay how is this car otherwise has it
given you many problems in the past
um it has i put a door on it and
i uh closed it after i got it and it
doesn't um it's my driver's door the
door doesn't open anymore so i have to
get into the passenger side
but it takes me
it's pretty funny it takes me to where i
gotta go and there's no complaints so
um i've had cars like that
this is one that needs a name right here
okay so if this car if you if if the car
was running if everything was doing okay
what can you get for the car today
i could probably get like seven hundred
dollars
there's so much rust on it um
yeah okay i don't think that's true i
think you could probably get a thousand
fifteen hundred so let's call it that
okay if the car was if the car was
running right if you had the catalytic
converter on it it does not increase the
value of the car that much because if it
was all fixed up and everything was
running just right
it really still wouldn't be worth much
more than that would it
you're right yeah so you're throwing
good money after bad because the formula
you use on fixing a hoopty which you're
driving a hooptie right i mean you're
driving a yes and so the formula is if
the value of the car plus the repair
the current value of the car
plus the repair
is more than the value of the car after
it's fixed
you don't fix the car and that's the
case here
so we're going to sell this car as is
take that money
plus the 2000 you are gonna spend
on a catalytic converter and buy a car
that's probably three times better than
this car
for 3 500 bucks
yeah it's all right still probably not
going to be the most glamorous car
exactly so here's the thing when you're
buying up an upgrade hoopty
what you're looking for
is what we call a garage sale car you're
looking for an estate sale where the
little old lady drove it
just to sunday to school and back but
it's it's old
and the uh upholstery's bad
and whatever else so we had a guy
working here for a while he drove a 1994
granada
can you say land yacht
right
and it was formerly red
and it had faded so it's pretty much
pink
and then it got hit with a hail storm so
it was pink with acne
okay
the interior was horrendous
but the car listen to this man it had 20
000 actual miles on it
he bought it from his grandmother for
500 bucks and she never drove the thing
so mechanically
it was like perfect
but it was the ugliest car i think i've
ever seen in my life
but mechanically it was perfect because
when you're driving a hooptie you're not
driving the car to pick up chicks
you are not driving the car to impress
people at a stoplight right
you are driving a hooptie to get
somewhere and so all we care about is
the mechanical
condition of the car
and so you want to buy something that's
ugly that people make fun of that you
have to give it a name but it's
mechanically unbelievably fabulous and
you call it old blue or big red
or the one i had was a 1978
when i was going through bankruptcy a
guy loaned me i didn't even buy it he
loaned it to me in 1978 cadillac the
predominant color on the thing was bondo
but it was lights out mechanical
i mean it was a beast mechanically but
it looked like the beverly hillbillies
had pulled up to the stoplight
the vinyl roof was torn loose across the
front so when you drove it filled up
with air like a parachute on top
so when you stop the stop light your top
is settling right
and everybody's looking at you and you
know what when you when you get to that
point you don't care what anybody thinks
because all i want to do is get to work
because i'm going to get to work so i
can get rid of this stupid car so i can
get a reasonable car but all you're
looking for is mechanical reliability
not sex appeal
that's the car you're looking for and
for 3 500 bucks you wouldn't believe how
great a car you can buy
with mechanical reliability and zero sex
appeal yep one of the things i love
about working here is we have so many
people who are working through the baby
steps paying off debt and when you drive
through our lot you see there's hey when
people go home at night there's all
spots out there
right i'm telling people proud of it and
around here it's a badge of courage it's
a badge of honor it's not we don't make
fun of people around here it's like
high-fiving them like you're doing what
it takes man drive like no one else
later you can drive like me
there you go doesn't it i used to i used
to drop that stuff now i don't drive
stuff like that anymore this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at aaa
825.5225.
you know i want to keep on this car
thing for just a minute
because it's so interesting
one of the things i emotionally realized
somewhere along our financial journey
and it wasn't with the cadillac that was
all the pieces with bondo or any of that
but it was um
it was after that there's there's
something about purchasing a car
a it's a very expensive thing it's one
of the largest things we buy other than
our home money-wise most people anyway
and um
so
but we have this sense
that a car purchase is such a and i
think it's because the amount of money
and it also takes up a large physical
space it's a it's not a it's not a tiny
little item it's a big thing right right
i guess it's those two things but
somewhere in our psyche
uh we ought to ask dr john doloney about
this see if he can tell us what happens
but
because i my theory is because the size
of the money and because of the size it
physically takes up it's one of the
larger things in both of those
categories we do
that we have this we
assign
too much
permanence
to the purchase of a car we buy a car
like we're going to drive it 40 years
and nobody does
and if you buy a bad car
sell it it's just a car get another one
but we our emotions don't work that way
very few people
change cars like every year
very very few people
and um
i uh uh
uh you know i and i i don't i don't
trade cars a lot i don't move up in car
very often and and i'm not a big jump
around and all that kind of thing either
but and and i think though that
we stress out about
selling a car
like it's the end of the world we're
never gonna get another guys never see a
nice car again
or buying a car we're like if we did
this wrong it's it'll be we're stuck
forever there's a permanence to it that
we assign psychologically that's just
not true
that makes sense yeah
and it i think it causes us a lot of
stress around vehicles that we don't
need it's just a stupid car you get
another one i mean 3 500 cars they're
like throwaway cars yeah 2000 dollar
cars like a throwaway car
i wonder if it's all supposed to buy a
big screen tv if it goes out do you get
it fixed no you go get another one it's
a throwaway
but we but with a car we're like oh god
you know if you spend a thousand dollars
on big screen tv you spend a thousand
dollars on a car you treat it
psychologically completely different
well i think part of the challenge for a
lot of people is it's something that's
out there like it's something that other
people see so they still attach a lot of
their value to it a lot of their status
to it and there's kind of that feeling
that's mixed into it too but the
permanence the sense that i'm stuck in
the decision
is unique to vehicles
[Music]
and houses houses people do that with
too but and it is legitimately harder to
jump in and out of a house
but like
i had to work walk myself through this i
don't know three or four years ago i had
a raptor and
i saw this really cool 600 horsepower
uh killer
f-150 roush but it wasn't a raptor
and i went down to the ford dealer that
this friend of mine and i'm like yeah
i'm doing that and so i drove home in
that other one i took sharon down there
and she's like whatever do whatever yeah
okay all right so whatever i'm doing it
so i bought the thing and i hated that
truck
almost immediately
wow it was completely different than
drive and feel and everything else and i
just didn't like it
and uh so i had the mufflers changed on
i tried to do some other stuff it was
really big engines wonderful powerful
great truck there anything wrong with it
i just didn't like it
and i'm sitting around i don't know my
crook look at my truck and i had to walk
myself through well doofus sell it then
you know it's a stupid truck so i went
and traded it and got a raptor you know
and it cost me some i lost a little bit
of money on my stupid
impulsivity but but the point is it's
not as permanent
you're not stuck it's a car
get another one
you know it's a 3 000 car it's a
throwaway car it's a garage sale car go
to you know go to an estate sale and bid
500 bucks you can get you another one
you know i don't want your whole yard
littered with cars get rid of the other
ones but but but
it's not just because it's a large thing
does not mean it's permanent right and i
think that can give people some freedom
to embrace the hooptie right yeah that's
the point yeah
it's just a you know it that this is a
snapshot it's a moment in time you're
not gonna be driving but when you're in
the hooptie land be sure you take
pictures
and heart and print them out
and put them in a frame and label it big
red
you know old blue whatever it is right
the green monster whatever you know how
many i mean people out there all of you
in radio land raise your hand i want to
see you
right but how many of you had when you
were kids you your parents had a car
that had a name
we always had names for our cars
you know we're going down to kmart get
it get in big blue i mean here we go you
know i mean that's
it's you know but we don't do that
anymore because the cars aren't junky
anymore they're not they don't have any
personality they're all just look just
alike and they you can't even tell the
difference in the dadgum hyundai and
alexis out there half the time nowadays
they all look alike and so
but the there's something about this
psychology around cars that ends up
costing us a lot of money it is not
permanent if you are driving a piece of
crap just grin about it take pictures
because it's temporary you're driving
like he said like we say
you're driving like no one else so later
you can drive
and give and live like no one else yeah
i wish people could just embrace the
feeling that we have here even in our
parking lot at ramsey where people do
have the pride in a junky car because
it's so that they can get out of debt
and get to building wealth it's so that
they can get to that next level and and
there's almost like you said a badge of
honor where it's like this is this is
awesome this is going to be something we
look back at when we're baby step
millionaires and go haha i remember that
season like
that's you got to have a story you tell
the grandkids like back in or 22
i was driving a hoop to you that the
door didn't work and i had to climb in
the other side you got to have something
to tell the grandbabies someday right
the great grand babies
you know get you get your denture
adjusted there when you're telling your
story right i mean you gotta backing off
22 but if you just if you all you back
in all 22 i had payments and so now i'm
still broke that ain't a good story we
don't want to do that one
you want to live like no one else and
drive like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else no discipline
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest
of righteousness
nothing that is great ever happens
without a level of perseverance a level
of pain that you push through and you
might as well realize it's temporary
right it's temporary
it's not permanent if you're if you're
sacrificing in order to win you're going
to win
if you're not sacrificing to win don't
expect to win
you know and that's that this car thing
is all wrapped up in this because you
get these people you know i got a 742
car payment yeah right how much is your
house payment 500 bucks why i live in a
trailer dude if your truck payments
bigger than your house payment you might
be a redneck i mean really we have these
people do this stuff all the time and
you gotta go gee
so and i did it i mean i i did it with
zeros on the end because i'm a car guy i
love vehicles but um
i think it's important that people get
around people in their lives too that
are embracing the hooptie that's why i
think it's so great when people can get
in a financial piece university class in
person because they're around other
people who are also hustling and
grinding and doing what it takes to get
out of debt versus your other broke
friends who have 700 car payments who
are all comparing who has the coolest
car and they don't feel you know you
feel that pressure to them no money
right they're broke
looking good and no money
i mean that's the definition of stupid
right there
you know looking good no money
this is completely backwards and
immature the definition
you know adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good one
definition of maturity is the ability to
delay pleasure for a greater good
and so mature people emotionally
exercise
and and me i got to stay away from the
donuts
dadgum donuts they kill me i get big as
a house eating these donuts and so i i
have to you know i have to con self
control
self control this is the actions of an
adult at 62 or at 22.
and this the man it just works it just
works it just works and we're so so many
of you out there are doing this stuff so
well i'm so proud of all of you well the
good good time the good news about the
hoopties it's just for a season donuts
unfortunately you may need to avoid
forever
come you mean i don't get if i eat like
no one else later i can't eat like no
one else i don't think it's all right
you know what that's true that one
doesn't work there
it's depressing the bummer it's
depressing thanks christina for ending
the hour on that note
wow
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
uh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships christina ellis number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five caden is with us in new york hi
kaden how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so i just graduated high school and i'm
headed to college this fall i have my
undergraduate all financially figured
out debt-free
but i want to go to medical school and i
have no idea how i'm going to do that
without taking out student loans
well good job on figuring out your
undergrad debt free that's awesome how
are you doing that
um well i've just gotten enough
scholarships and the rest i can just
work through
that's outstanding way to go
well thank you
yeah um medical school that's amazing i
love that you're already having that
insight and that vision to start
thinking about it right now the fact
that you're in high school still and
already dreaming that up shows that
you're really bright and smart and
competitive in school so i love that
going to medical school debt-free i'm
sure you've heard a lot of people say
it's a bit more challenging
and and it is it is more challenging but
the fact that you're already researching
it and you are bright gives me great
hope that you can get some of the
scholarships and fellowships available
for
for medical school
um i would encourage you to start
researching early like you're doing now
i mean start learning about these
programs so a lot of these programs that
are available to go to do medical school
debt free
like i said they're competitive so what
do you need to be doing in undergrad
to be the candidate that qualifies for
those programs i think that's the
biggest thing you focus on right now is
what do i need to do what needs to be
true in my life to really stand out in
the process of winning a scholarship or
a fellowship or one of these really
amazing programs that helped pay for
medical school yeah
one of the things you want to look
towards caden is a product called the md
phd program
and that's where you become an employee
of the university
and uh then employees go to school free
and um
that's very tough again they're very
competitive it falls under the heading
of what christina was saying it's a type
of fellowship is what it is
but um the program is out there and it
can be done yeah but your you know their
academics are uh and grade point average
is going to enter into it for sure
uh but other things other things other
things will as well so study that start
figuring out that the other thing i urge
you is and i don't know what i guess
it's like a lot of things in higher
education
people don't stop to realize that
there's a vast spectrum of what you can
pay
the difference in med school a and med
school b in cost is dramatic
and so i'm going to start researching
you know what is the cheapest med
schools in america
and i'm going to be applying there
because you're going to need you know
you don't want to go to the most
expensive med school in america unless
they're going to give you a free ride
but if they've got scholarships or
you've got a fellowship or something
like that then we'll go there
um
of course there is the military
and they'll pay for it
and you're and you're gonna serve your
country by being a doc for the military
for a while as part of that
program um
you know and but that that is an option
that's one of the things that's out
there the national guard uh has a
similar program as well so but but again
you've got to look at what how long
you're willing to tie yourself up after
med school
in a military career if you're that's a
trade-off uh
versus the debt that you're going to go
in versus going into the debt uh the
last thing
is is really a needle in a haystack but
i'm going to throw it out there anyway
because i've heard about it happening a
couple of times
there are
a there is a shortage of docks
in
rural areas and in
what are called underserved areas
typically like an inner city type
situation and there is a student loan
forgiveness program
for those
that's not what i'm recommending but in
those situations
some of the big hospital companies like
for instance hca
may have from time to time
a program that feels a little bit like
the military program where they're
willing to pay for you to be a doc but
you agree to serve
in
uh out in a corn field somewhere for the
next five years after that and instead
of instead of at a metro hospital in a
uh a cushy job thing uh or whatever i
don't know what the trade-off is but
learn about that and also in that same
haystack where there's a couple of
needles the drug companies uh there
there's occasions i have heard of
uh scholarships through them for med
students because they love the idea of
being nice to future docs so future docs
prescribe their brand
okay
so that loan forgiveness thing that's
not like through the government because
i've been listening to your show for uh
that is that is through the government
but i'm not recommending that
okay okay that's like a last resort yeah
and it's a different kind of loan
forgiveness than the kind we trash on
here all the time this is the
underserved that one actually happens
and it's a three to a five year
turnaround on it it's not the 10-year
and 98 of the people that apply don't
get it that's the private student loan
forgiveness or the public student
unforgiveness program that one's a joke
it's a scam okay but the one i'm talking
about actually does happen in the
medical field
it's unique to them it's unique to the
medical field maybe
nurses but i don't remember docs for
sure but it's like fifty thousand bucks
they'll forgive but if you're three
hundred thousand dollars in debt because
you went to a stupid expensive school
then fifty thousand bucks doesn't help
you for being in an underserved area
there's a lot of ways to get it the
point you brought up is the most
important point a he's getting started
early
b he sounds like he's really sharp oh
and you know the thing i can bring up
he's got four years while he's in school
right work
that's a lot
right i mean what if you made fifty
thousand dollars a year for four years
because you worked all the time
that'll serve you well
50 000 a year and you don't have hardly
any expenses that's 200 000 bucks
i think we just solved it i mean
work's a surefire money making scheme
and it gets the experience it gets you
prepared for whatever you're going to do
next particularly if you could work in
the field
you know the ken coleman idea proximity
principle what if you were working in a
hospital and
you know all these docs and hospital
companies and people you run into execs
are trying to figure out a way to help
you go to med school free that'd be
pretty cool kristen is in st louis and
we're going to come back to you kristen
after the commercial break i looked down
my clock and realized i was out of time
so
one of the cool things with him too is
just keeping those options open the fact
that he's looking this early and he's
got this time to lay things out the
biggest thing with higher education that
seems like a lot of people don't do
is really explore all the options before
they make a decision it's like get those
options written down on paper and then
evaluate what needs to be true in my
life in order for me to qualify for that
scholarship in order for me to be able
to pay for that school and really dig
deep and figure out you know there's not
just one path there's a
variety of options you can do yeah i
mean i've heard so many people feel they
put themselves in a situation where they
feel trapped they go well i was only
approved for one medical school and so
it's the only one i can do
it's gonna be seven hundred thousand
dollars but it's the only one i can do
you know you know well that
knows a possible answer too you know
right
you know so you gotta you gotta take
some of these things off the table
and go we're gonna go a route uh that
involves no debt and if you take debt
off the table
then you have to scratch and figure out
and be creative and hustle and grind
your way through it you'll find a way
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina i think there is a month for
everything now august is national make a
will month
oh brother
that's a thing
well you do need to make a will though
so if you don't have an up-to-date will
then and you don't have your estate plan
in order then maybe august make a will
month and we'll remind you to do it
sounds silly but you should be doing it
so here's the thing uh what are you
waiting for there's no need to you need
to knock this out you can't wait wait
wait wait wait you're not more likely to
die if you have a will
it doesn't enter into it you're not
going to live you're going to die
eventually someday nobody gets out of
this thing alive everyone needs a will
estate planning covers all the documents
the plans the conversations you need to
have for when something happens to you
not if something is going to happen to
you someday
and no you don't have to be an eccentric
millionaire with an offshore account to
have an estate plan it just means that
there's a plan
because you're going to have an estate
and a good estate plan protects your
family's future and everybody knows
what's going on and every you know your
wishes are carried out because they're
now in a legal document
start by checking out our estate
planning guide it is free
and it's an easy to use tool
that will help you keep track of
everything that you need to do it walks
you through which documents to get
like your will
if you don't have one as an example what
conversations to have
where you can go to get more information
give yourself and your loved ones peace
of mind by figuring this stuff out ahead
of time download your complete guide to
estate planning for free
after all it's national make a wheel
month
at ramsey solutions dot com slash estate
guide ramsey solutions dot com slash
estate guide
it's free go get it do the work do the
work be an adult
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they're going to remake your blinds for
free you have free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from miranda in mississippi i'm a 20
year old who is struggling and feel like
debt is inevitable for me i took out a
private loan for five thousand dollars
after paying off my first year and a
semester of school by myself my savings
account has been drained and i have not
been the best budgeter how can i avoid
loans when i have no money i need to be
enrolled and go to school i am at a loss
as to how to move forward
well first of all miranda
i would take a deep breath and give
yourself some grace a lot of people are
not great budgeters when they're 20. um
i love that you're asking this question
the fact that you're you know writing in
and you're interested in budgeting says
a lot so
first of all just don't speak that
you're not a great budgeter over you
because i think you have so much room
for growth and a lot of people who start
budgeting don't feel like they're great
budgeters a lot of people are like oh
we say that it typically takes people
about three months to start getting good
at a budget so give yourself grace with
that but with the college situation the
first thing i do is talk to your
financial aid office you're obviously
already in school so sit down with a
financial aid officer and explain your
situation explain that you don't have
the money to pay for school you're not
going to take out any more loans so ask
them you know is there any other extra
funding available a lot of schools offer
discounts
on tuition so see if you're eligible for
any additional discounts to be able to
make ends meet see if there are any
other scholarships available that maybe
you could apply for or that they have
they can actually just give you um and
see if there are any other jobs on
campus but that point person can kind of
explain what's available at your school
so that you can get kind of a true
number that you now need to figure out
so you know that's the very first point
person and then of course working um
getting jobs off campus a lot of times
if you look off campus you can get jobs
that pay a bit more than what you can
find working at the library at your
school or somewhere on campus so see
what's available there and make 25
an hour cleaning toilets
yup walking dogs
babysitting
a lot of retail jobs are getting close
to that too now yeah
and uh miranda you're not working
there's nothing in here that indicates
at all that you're doing any work
and you need to work like a lot
yep like all the time
like 40 hours a week
how do i go let's go you're gonna go to
school you're just not going to have
much of a social life oh well
so what is the what is the goal here
what's the primary goal if i can only
get one thing done in the next four
years social life
or school which am i going to do
because you're going to choose
well it's to give the rest of your life
to have a great social life so
be willing to invest now and work hard
so that you can really enjoy and have
freedom after you graduate it's just a
temporary sacrifice for a really massive
long-term benefit
and then also when you're looking at
jobs off campus though really be
strategic don't just jump on the first
job that you see a lot of companies are
offering tuition benefit programs so see
if you can get a high hourly rate plus
see if you can find somebody who'll
actually pay for your college tuition or
give you a portion of that because
there's a lot of people out there doing
that and you want to be as strategic as
possible yeah i you know there was a
thing and i think it's still rolling out
there that a bunch of these companies
fedex ups target chili's
several of these other companies were
offering school tuition
and work yeah it's actually in the world
it's like 20 an hour
i mean it's it's yeah so look for stuff
like that
well the challenge with that is you may
need to transfer to make that happen so
a lot of these jobs are offering free
tuition benefits for certain colleges so
i don't know what college you're going
to you may be going to a college that
costs 60 000 a year and if you have no
money and you're not getting a lot of
financial aid or scholarships from that
school you may need to consider
going somewhere else and going to a job
that offers free tuition benefits and it
may be to a state school it may not be
to the most you know prestigious school
in the area but if it's free
that's incredible you don't graduate
that free and still get a great job yup
absolutely absolutely i prestige the
prestige of the school does not enter
into the decision at all you don't have
any money
and so and prestigious schools have no
track record whatsoever of causing you
to be successful zero
so i don't really care about the
prestige of the school at all
you need to be studying something that's
applicable and studying it people that
are really reasonable and teaching it
and get plugged in so i don't know where
you are in mississippi miranda but um
lots and lots and lots of hard work
lots of plugging into companies that
while you're working and earning money
also have scholarship programs getting
scholarships going to the counselor's
office like uh christina is saying here
and all of that comes together and where
you're going to school
how you're working and how you're
getting scholarships those are the three
things that get people through debt free
but i think it's important for sometimes
people to stop and go i may not be at
the right school i think that's a really
hard pill to swallow but people who were
taking out student loans they
caught on to the show and they're going
oh my gosh i don't want to take any more
student loans out you may need to
transfer schools you may have to because
i mean you may be a place you can't
afford yeah you may look up and i bought
a car i can't afford i gotta sell the
car and it's inconvenient in the short
term but long run
it's completely worth the effort well i
mean there's so much emotion tied to i
got in and this is my school
but it's true i mean you know
a lot of emotion tied to that and i get
it i get it i mean it's nice to go
somewhere the emotion is legitimate but
it's a bad decision-making tool right
and it can be very costly in the long
run oh it can be out of control yeah in
order just to not deal with the emotion
of moving schools and how painful that
would be
uh you end up 150 000 in debt that would
be under the stupid column yeah you know
because you wouldn't deal with you and
uh it's just hard it really is and it's
like um i was talking to a dad the other
day he's like my my daughter's dream
school and it's going to be 200 000
she's going to be 200 000 in debt when
she comes out and i'm like that's not
your daughter's dream school that's
called a nightmare
it's not a dream it's a nightmare dad
you have to grow you know dad come on
suck it up tell your daughter she's
being a
don't do it don't do it tell her she's
being dumb
and you know no don't participate in
this
ridiculous process
no
no it's not a dream
when you're 200 000 in debt that's not a
dream
that that that sets you up for a decade
you set you're setting your finances
back a decade
because of your dream school oh shoot me
it is not your dream it's a freaking
nightmare you ought to wake up in the
middle of night screaming
right you just had a horrible like you
went to a horror movie in your head
no it's a nightmare it's a nightmare
no
it's not a dream
don't confuse the two and dads and moms
be a parent
be a parent look at them and say no
i'm old crusty and i'm not dumb
no you're not doing that you're young
wet behind the ears and dumb no you're
not doing that i love you too much to
let you create a
decade's worth of pain for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five christina ellis number
one best-selling author ramsey
personalities my co-host kristen is with
us in st louis hi kristin what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
uh so my question is about baby step 3b
so my husband and i are looking at
starting this step soon i'm due to
graduate with my nurse practitioner
degree in may and since we cashflowed
this program we'll be getting done
debt-free ding ding way to go
thank you how'd you do that um well i uh
worked full time until clinicals and
then my husband got turned into side
hustle to pay for the rest of the
program so wow
there you go okay good well done okay so
what's your question
so um we own some farmland that we're
planning on building on and so i've
heard you talk about um step 3b with
buying a home but my question is what is
your recommendation for step 3b with
building a home like with how much to
save before starting or just your
recommendations of that is the land paid
for
so it the farm is
it's kind of like the farm
pays for itself we kind of use that as a
business for the itself is it debt-free
it is not okay um so how much do you owe
on it
oh
it we just got it
[Music]
two years ago and so we just started
paying for it it's about 55 acres what
do you owe on it
200
okay and what's it worth
it's now it land in our area skyrocketed
so it
worked much more than what's it worth
i honestly don't know give me again
completely honest with you give me a
guess um
honestly probably about
400 i was gonna guess 400 yeah okay
that's good yeah all right and your
household income is what
um right now roughly 80
and since i'm not working but once i get
done we're looking at doubling that okay
so you're going to be making 190 000
bucks a year 160 000 bucks a year
something like that right and um you
have 200 000 worth of equity
and that that will form as your down
payment if you go apply for a
construction loan because when you apply
for a construction loan what they're
going to do is they're going to
probably not take a second position to
your existing mortgage they're probably
going to pay off your existing mortgage
in the construction loan so that they
are the mortgage on the property
and then they're going to let you draw
down against the rest of the
construction loan to build the house
okay
and then when it's all over uh if you
spend 300 000 on the house you had a 200
000 mortgage to start with then you're
to have a 500 000 permanent mortgage
that pays off the construction loan
okay when it's all done
but the fact that you have 200 000 worth
of equity makes this deal happen today
with zero cash down payment
okay
because you've got this equity that
rolls into the deal and you're you know
it's going to be as if you put down two
hundred thousand dollars because if like
if we use my numbers if you build a 300
000 house on it you've got uh you've got
500 in debt but the property's gonna be
worth 700.
okay and so that gives them the equity
position that you need for the permanent
mortgage for a traditional mortgage
because if you put 200 down on a 700
deal that'd be great right
right that's the same math situation you
find yourself in then so
what's gonna happen is you're gonna have
to have a
a a certified contractor
in your state you're going to have to
have a set of plans
that are not on a brown paper bag
that an appraiser can actually use to
appraise the plan as if the house was
completed
and the bank is going to require these
things in order for you to get to build
the house
okay you can't just make this crap up
and they're going to give you a half
million dollar they're going to give you
you know to do this thing with and so
the certified contractor the fact the
appraisal on the plans tells them that
when it's done
by the certified contractor when it's
completed on schedule and on budget then
they're not going to be at risk the
bank's not going to have too much in the
thing the third thing they're going to
make you do is go ahead and get your
permanent mortgage and the permanent
mortgage that
get it get qualified for it all the
paperwork done they will issue then what
the permanent mortgage will issue what's
called a take-out letter
and the letter states that you have the
mortgage in place to take out
the construction loan because
construction loan is temporary lending
right so you take it out you remove it
with the permanent mortgage when you're
done now some banks will do the
permanent mortgage in-house
and the construction loan in-house
churchill mortgage can do that for you
too
okay and so then you don't have to go to
two different places to get it but in
every case
you know oh my husband's really good
he's gonna do the building himself
that's not gonna work right or here's
our plan we sketched it out on some on a
brown paper sack that's not gonna work
they're not gonna give you the money
right very professional button-down
process here just like you learned when
you went to med school but it's applied
to the building industry
okay perfect you can do this though you
don't have to have a whole bunch of 3b
to pull it off y'all start working on it
you're going to have to have your job in
place because you're going to have the
income you don't have enough income now
to support this program but when your
job's there you're going to do it that's
pretty cool they've done a great job
yeah that's outstanding that's exciting
to start visioning that up too that's
very exciting that you can sit there on
55 acres and start dreaming up what
that's going to be like yeah that's
going to be a nice place nice place
especially with a nice bump in income
too you guys are gonna be able to get to
that spot where you know you're working
through the baby steps and paying it off
pretty quickly once you're all you know
what that's true they're gonna be making
before they know it they'll be making a
couple of hundred and they'll be able to
plow through that thing pretty quick
noah's in sacramento hi noah how can we
help
hey dave i've got a question i've got a
considerable amount of student debt in a
parent plus loan and i'm trying to
figure out how to make affordable
payments on a loan that's in my parent's
name which feels feels a little bit
unaffordable at the moment
what's the total amount of debt
uh it is 175.
and good lord are you a doctor or a
lawyer
neither one what did you get your degree
in
uh christian ministries i'm a pastor
for 175 000 haulers
yeah
okay
bad choice and um
god that was not
you may be called to the ministry you
weren't called to this mess um
the uh what is your what is your
household income
uh 60 000. oh son
i'm so sorry
so mom and dad took out these loans
their parent plus loans
correct and they can't pay them
they they i mean they can pay part our
agreement was that we would split at
half before i went to school that was
the that was the agreement
are they struggling to pay them right
now
they've been in deferment and
forbearance and whatnot so nobody's made
any payments on them at this point and i
mean my parents household income is
considerably more
uh than ours we're just trying to figure
out uh again i i don't know how a lot of
this works but i've been told by the the
lender and why not that we can't
like consolidate them into my name or
anything like that and so we're just
trying to figure out what to do they're
gonna be in their name you're just gonna
assist in the payment of it and so
they're going to give you like their
password and the website and you're
going to jump on there and pay payments
on their loan
it's their loan it's going to be their
loan until it's over
but you're just your your moral
agreement your handshake is that you're
picking up half of it
and so um what what does your wife make
she's not working at the moment we have
a young daughter and she's pregnant
literally nine days past her due date
today oh wow that's her second kid
congratulations uh so i i assume she's
planning on going back to work though
uh yeah when we don't have very young
children yes that's the plan
okay
all right well i mean you're just going
to be paying payments on this no one
noah um
and the math is telling me that this is
a highly stressful situation
so it is i i
i think you're going to be running
you're going to be what we call a
bi-vocational pastor
uh you're going to be running side
hustles of some kind there's nothing
wrong with that it doesn't if it doesn't
most pastors statistically one number i
saw was 80 percent of them are by
vocational in america right now
and there's no shame in that it's not
it doesn't diminish your call
it doesn't do any of that but
it's not unusual at all for a
young pastor to be by vocational you're
gonna have to have some more money
it's a mathematical problem you got
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today philippians 3 14 i
press on toward the goal for the prize
of the upward call of god in christ
jesus
jim rohn said motivation is what gets
you started
habit is what keeps you
going
i um
i i should walk away from the car wreck
but i can't so um
it's i i think we have to um
we have a responsibility to address
the uh situation with the last call
so let's go back again because you're
the education expert here at ramsey
you're the one that got half million
dollars in
scholarships and you study this stuff
and work with students everywhere
moms and dads
the
higher education community
is at best
irresponsible
at worst
con artists
they are willing to charge you
any amount of money
that you can figure out a way to pay
that does not justify itself
in the career field that the person is
going into
so you can spend 300 000 and go with 300
000 in debt
with higher education and get a degree
in left-handed polka history
completely useless
and you will be a three hundred thousand
dollar in debt barista
moms and dads this is the environment
we're in
and even seminaries
will charge you
175 thousand dollars to be a pastor and
get a job making sixty thousand dollars
that is illogical
it is not i'm a christian it is not good
stewardship
the seminary that did that should be
ashamed of themselves
until you let a young man go 300 000 and
175 000 in debt
to become a pastor
you ought to be ashamed of yourself if
you're in higher education and you're
allowing that to happen
and you've got an 18 year old signing up
for that and you did that how do you
sleep at night
because there's no economics
justification for this at all well it's
god's call on the young man's life
absolutely i believe in god's call on a
young man's or young woman's life i
believe in that i also believe jesus can
do math
and i'm positive there's scripture all
over the place that indicates that we
are to be good managers
good stewards
of opportunities that are in front of us
of financial
decisions that are in front of us and
if if you put if you put it's all going
to work out because god said and then
you go do something stupid and you blame
it on god you ought to have your butt
kicked because your christian doctrine
is awful
it's horrible
and i'm not just yelling at this last
young man that called i'm just about to
cry for him i feel so sad for him
he's getting ready to have a second baby
any minute
he makes 60 000 a year and between his
parents and him and the seminary that
messed him over
he ends up 175 000 in debt
someone
out of the three of those people that
call themselves adults at some point
should have raised their hand and said
uh this is stupid
yeah a hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars in debt for a profession that
does not on average make enough to pay
that off that is
asinine and honestly it's even more
painful to see that it was a parent plus
loan because that means a parent vouched
for that and signed up off on that it'd
be different if you could even say you
know it was an 18 year old who went off
out on his own and signed off for loans
by himself but
this is a parent and that's why well
it's just it's not just i mean
christians justify it sometimes with our
with it with a toxic version of
christianity like well it's god's
calling his life we have to do it you
know
no god does not call you to do stupid
things
the blessings of the lord have no sorrow
added to them
if their sorrow added to it it was not
god
and so i don't question whether the
young man was called into ministry i am
a hundred percent sure god did not tell
him to do 175 000 in debt there's too
much scripture that comes against that
idea
and the same thing is true not just in
that but if you want to help people and
you want to go into social work great
i want to be i i've got i'm going to get
a master's in sociology okay great what
are you going to do i'm going to work
for the state as a caseworker great
you're going to make 30
to 48 000 a year
you cannot
go 300 000 in debt to get your masters
in sociology
that's stupid
stop it
god
it's unbelievable
it's ridiculous
and this is rachel talked about this
when we first started talking about
student loans she said we don't have a
student loan crisis we have a parenting
crisis moms and dads step up and stop
this
have
a brain and a backbone to go with it
stop it
when junior comes in and goes i want to
go 300 000 in debt to be a a social
worker with a master's degree say no
that's stupid
i want to get a degree in
music
uh so i can be a band leader at the
local high school and i'm going to go
200 000 in debt no
no
well you don't believe in music yes i
believe in music i don't believe in
music as a backdrop to your child's
nightmare
that's absolute your
band leaders at you know the do the
marching band at the local high school
do not make enough money
to justify 150 000 in student loan debt
that's stupid
we have to stop this and your stupid
butt congress keeps signing off on this
and you and i are responsible for it
because they're
federally insured student loans when
they go bad the taxpayer eats it
god and it's not that junior can't have
the career they can still be the band
director the social worker they can
still be a pastor but start at community
college then go to a public four-year
school
study in a way that you can afford to do
it right
hello there's so many other options
please
that just breaks my heart for that kid
i just i ca i just i want to cry
it makes me so angry at this seminary
how immoral is that
in the name of god to be doing this
immoral thing in the name of jesus i you
ought to be
oh
it's ridiculous we have to do better i
mean that's ridiculous and if they're
willing to mess your kid over you have
to be willing to stop it from happening
and all education is not ordained it's
not god ordained and it is not
economically ordained all education is
not worth it so if you want to become
the band director at the local high
school i am not putting that down at all
if you want to be a social worker a
caseworker at the state i am not putting
that down at all but use some freaking
intellect
when you're dealing with your education
to be stupid about education is as
ironic as anything i can think of
and use math
god he's mad please
please sixth grade math
yeah how are you going to pay this back
making that answer not
then don't do it
it's all going to work out because all
education's good no when you're stupid
about education you're stupid about
everything
because it's just just he's got two
little babies and he's just
trapped
ah
brand new baby getting ready to come any
minute
i'm just livid on the people that
allowed this to occur
i'm a tiny bit mad at him he was an
adult in the process but i'm really
upset with his parents in the seminary
right and guys you got to know there is
a true
villain out there lurking
and higher education
will completely screw you
if you allow them to they have no
conscience about it none whatsoever
because they're so stupid they believe
the same thing some of you that are
doing this stuff do
and you just you have to stop it
you have to stop it this is the problem
with student loans if we quit making
student loans this stuff will go away
right we need to stop this program it is
congress stop destroying your citizenry
with this
you're screwing our own people stop it
god i'm so bad
and you can get a debt-free degree
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you